guys we all love competitive games that
feeling after clutching around or
ranking up this can't be beat but
sometimes that postgame feeling isn't so
positive sometimes all you're left with
is pure rage and the desire to destroy
whatever inanimate object happens to be
around you so today we look back at all
those moments that make you want to
smash your keyboard and punch your
monitor and they tilt it just thinking
about it here are the top 10 moments
that make you want to rage any sports
starting us off are these silent killers
of easily winnable games lag and bugs
look at that what it would appear the
Palmas somehow dropped through the wall
below them up what are the chances
you'll be the first to find an invisible
deathtrap in the middle of a very
winnable game well if you're dr. Lupo
they're pretty high hello
took the El hello and you instantly died
yeah lag is especially devastating since
you could be hitting all the right
buttons to win a fight but not have it
reach the server's in time curtain back
[Music]
coming in at number 9 on our list is
that moment a critical buffer item is
snatched away from your very grasp
[Applause]
getting what you thought was your barren
stolen by a drive-by porky rocket will
leave you wanting to switch teams an ad
carry being an encounter strike there's
nothing worse than having your friend
drop it off for you only to have it
stolen by some random throws it off the
map it's these moments that make you
consider risking it all for the team
[Music]
is it a bird is it a plane no it's a
super fed Diana coming into the speed of
light - one shot you take the number 8
spot on our list yes we're talking about
getting insta-kill about not being able
to play the damn game about getting
involuntarily transferred to spectator
mode in one frustrating rage-inducing
instant if it can kill you instantly
well it'll leave you salty as hell I'm
actually gonna [ __ ] coming in at number
7 on our list are Timo and techies when
you load into a game of League of
Legends or dota your expectation is to
play a MOBA not [ __ ] minesweeper but
when you face a techies or a Teemo the
game stops being about destroying the
enemy base and becomes a nightmare full
of invisible minds well this is what we
call Baron control and now the headaches
begin for jinair they still have two
blue trinkets only one sweeper -
apparently you're stepping on shrooms
guys you've heard the song before every
step you take every move you make will
be utterly terrifying because techies
and Timo have turned the entire map into
a deathtrap poised to make you rage
[Music]
what is [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] stupid
camp [ __ ] you [ __ ] solo lanes are where
gentlemen go to play league of legends
there a place for gallant Knights to
have their honorable 1v1 duels except
when the jungler comes in and ruins
everything I'm actually playing that's
right number six on our list is that
horrible moment when the enemy jungler
decides to pitch a tent in your lane
their goal is not only to make sure you
can't play the game but to make sure
you're pissed about it you want the
opportunity to do a little bit more
damage I'd like the opportunity to play
League of Legends well fortnight chapter
2 is finally here and I think I can
speak for everyone when I say good
riddance to those broken necks the
number 5 entry on our list
terrorized fortnight for far too long
[Music]
how many [ __ ] hate everything about
these [ __ ] mechs
they can go [ __ ] themselves if Epic
Games is watching my stream don't [ __ ]
yourself until you take these out of the
game because they don't [ __ ] you
anything positive they're all naked so
track yourself honestly calling those
1000 HP scuff Gundams overpowered is an
understatement
you could literally play fortnight with
your monitor turned off if you had a
mech
you got one
okay chat says that while there now
vaulted the Mex will forever be
remembered for the pure rage they caused
in fortnight coming in at number four
are all the unlucky Ragnaros fireballs
and pub G red zones yes we're talking
about RNG itself get rid of it
how many times has the community told
you blue balls nobody wants the red zone
nobody you guys make me sick make me
sick it's pathetic game design thinking
and balance why do you have randomized
red zones in the game huh it doesn't
make sense these moments of frustration
sting extra hard because of how unlikely
they are haven't happened enough and
you'll be convinced the universe is out
to get you just ask for third on our
list are those moments after rough games
those moments your teammates fed enough
to solve world hunger to try and forget
the previous disaster you queue again
and
14 days know why these not only two
games live in three games also are you
[ __ ] you want me to not be thought
segmentation running it down like my
games what are you doing about it I
imported them I said tickets to you you
did abandon you do [ __ ] there's nothing
more infuriating than getting banned
it's even toxic I'm going to kill her
for me why oh sure you wish death upon
your team and ran it down mid for ten
minutes but hey they deserved it right
[Music]
you would not feed this day just
queueing up can be the scariest thing to
do in a game not only do you have no
idea who your opponents will be you have
absolutely no clue who you're gonna team
up with from the boosted let's give us
up for all the boosted Grille mercy
man's out in there to the trolls it's a
complete crapshoot whether you'll
actually play a game of League or csgo
or if you're gonna have to spend the
next 15 minutes fighting not to rage
quit as you babysit a group of infants
it's man I'm playing with like I'm
losing my mind playing silver players
man look losing sucks but losing does
not give us the right to lose our [ __ ]
having someone call you trash after you
lose well that's when all rationality
goes out the window
getting BMD is extremely frustrating on
the one hand the opponent is
disrespecting you don't shoot me please
I'm a friend of yours stop no stop on
the other hand you did lose to him so
what can you do except fume in your
gaming chair as you fight the urge to
Hulk smash your peripherals
well guys that's our list now if we miss
the moment that makes you rage the most
you know what to do rage at us in the
comments section oh and don't forget to
like the video and go ahead and sub to
the channel if you're not one of the 1
million people who already has ah you
know Matt sometimes I question people
who rage in a game like how pathetic is
your life why do you care that much
I never rage two hours later get [ __ ]
so broken